hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Rainer Maria
Rilke is letters to a young poet one of
the central sets of topics that he picks
up and discusses with his interlocutor
have to do with sexuality and having sex
on the one hand and love on the other
and how these could come together for at
least in in our own time and in his own
time some people and hopefully for
everybody in a world yet to come his
picture is in some respects a bit
utopian and he's espousing a very
interesting form of feminism which some
would have trouble recognizing as such
and he's telling us that you know
there's there's something greater that
we can connect ourselves with but it
would take a lot of work a lot of labor
our bites in German on our part so he
talks about sex and loved his young
interlocutor as being difficult tasks he
never actually uses the word tasks in in
the German he says that these are things
that are laid upon us or these are
things that are assigned to us and this
is in
you know letter five and and letter
seven there is a really important
characteristic involved in this he says
sex is difficult yes but those tasks are
those things that have been entrusted to
us are difficult almost anything serious
is difficult and everything is serious
if you just recognize this and manage
out of yourself out of your own talent
in nature out of your own experience and
childhood and strength to achieve and
here he sketches out a bit of the sort
of vision for where this is going a holy
individual relation to sex one that is
not influenced by convention in just a
transliteration convention and custom
Zita then you will no longer have to be
afraid of losing yourself and becoming
unworthy of your dearest possession so
we have this incredibly important task
that is existential in the fact that we
all face it so long as we develop to you
know an age where we begin to experience
the desires for it so it's you know
those of us who make it into puberty and
beyond it is part of our existential
condition and it's not something that we
can simply take for granted as a bunch
of drives or inclinations it's something
that we're supposed to take on and
transform he also in letter seven says
it's good to love why because love is
difficult and then he goes on and he
says for one human being to love another
human being that is perhaps the most
difficult task that has been entrusted
to us the ultimate task the final test
and proof the work our might for which
all other work is merely preparation so
sex and love these two fundamental
things that are for so many people just
separate it off many of them just don't
believe in love at all Rilke thought
these are absolutely central that they
are some of the most important things in
our human existence
he goes on and he talks in letter seven
about young people and he's not engaging
in one of those sort of you know older
person's these young people today they
don't know what they're doing he's
talking about young people throughout
the ages and he's saying they're caught
in this tragic situation I really feel
bad for them why because he says young
people who are beginners and everything
are not yet capable of love and yet they
think they are they jump into things and
we live in a society where that is
highly encouraged and where love and sex
are totally blurred together for them
and also distinguished in ways that are
unhealthy as well so he says it's
something they must learn why loving he
says does not at first mean as love
songs tell us merging surrendering and
uniting with another person
why for what he says would a union be of
two people who are unclarified
unfinished and still incoherent instead
it's he says an inducement for the
individual to ripen to become something
in himself to become world to become
world in himself for the sake of another
person it's a great demanding claim on
him so if young people really love each
other they have to in some respect focus
on themselves and their relations to
things other than the love object that
they want to fuse with so that they can
become a genuine person capable of
having and supporting and sustaining
that relationship and that means the
other person has to do that too they
can't simply offer each other offer
themselves to each other and get it on
and hope that they're going to have love
develop out of that and he says this is
what young people are so often and so
just asterisks leave wrong and doing
they fling themselves at each other when
love takes hold of them they scatter
themselves in all their messiness
disorder bewilderment and what can
happen then
now notice Rilke is not saying this to
like condemn them or to say oh they're
there you know so messy these these
stupid kids get off my lawn no he's
saying this is unfortunate there's
nobody there to give them any helpful
guidance
about this other than you know a bunch
of rules don't have sex with anybody you
know be pure that's not going to be
helpful in developing a healthy
relationship he says what can happen
what can life do with this heap of half
broken things they call their communion
they would like to call their happiness
and their future each of them loses
himself for the sake of the other person
and loses the other and many others who
still wanted to come he says there is no
area of life seemingly you know
sexuality is this Drive that that you
know takes us out of conventions and
reveals us as the the true selves that
we are
he says that's BS there is no area of
life that is more beset by conventions
than sexuality it's and that's the way
it's always been for us human beings
he says they escape into one of the many
conventions that have been put up in
great numbers like public shelters on
this most dangerous road maybe they're
the good the good people who you know
just fool around a little bit and wait
until they're married maybe they're the
ones who are breaking all the rules but
they're breaking all the rules in the
same way that everybody else is maybe
they're in the middle of the road
somehow maybe they're doing their own
thing they find some kink that appeals
to them and then you know read about it
on the internet and and you know do to
find some some new ways of doing
something but nothing is new absolutely
I mean one thing this is a little bit
off-topic but one thing that you realize
in reading for example to sods
endless discussions of people copulating
is there's only so many ways you can put
human beings together and make them do
things and it loses its interest very
very quickly this is an area that has
completely beset by conventions he says
and he tells us that they sense their
failure many young people who love
falsely feel oppressed by their failure
they want to make the situation they've
landed in livable and fruitful in their
own personal way why because nature
tells them that questions of love cannot
be resolved publicly and according to
this or that agreement that they are
questions intimate questions from one
human
being to another thinking about sex that
way not as just getting it on not as
something that has become commodified
and turned into a million different
topics of discussion on everything from
blogs to Facebook to pick whatever else
you like
but as questions that we're asking each
other and it takes on a very different
aspect doesn't it he says that when they
act out of this mutual helplessness with
the best of intentions they try to
escape one convention that's approaching
them for example marriage they fall into
the clutches of some less obvious but
just as deadly convention and he says
that even what seems to be in the
ordinary sense of moral is simply
convention so this is a really important
problem what what is he suggesting well
he's saying that young people need to
learn to develop before they can really
get what is available there for us human
beings out of sex and out of love he
also talks about sexuality as being
shifting in our own time now he's
writing around the turn of the last
century in the early 1900s and so he's
seeing some some transformations in the
Europe of his own time and we might
think today about how far this has been
taken and how many steps have gone
forward and how many steps have gone
back and what this would look like for
us in the present he brings up for
example this author who he praises and
Richard demo and he says that you know I
think his works are really great you his
interlocutor have characterized him well
with the phrase living and writing and
heat and he says in fact the artist
experience lies so unbelievably close to
the sexual - its pain and pleasure that
the two phenomena are really just
different forms of one in the same
longing and bliss instead of heat one
could say sex sex in the great pure
sense of the term free of any sin
attached to it by the church then his
art would be great and infinitely
important but he says
there's a problem here what is it he
says instead of a completely ripe and
pure world of sexuality what we find in
his works is a world that is not human
enough as he says what does he mean
there well this is where we really want
to think things through
we are all humans but in some respects
we can be less than human because we
don't live up to the potential that we
actually have and some of that you could
say well I would be human as a man and
then you're human as whatever gender you
are
Rilke goes further than that he says
that this guy's work is not fully human
because it's only male says instead of a
complete completely ripe and pure world
of sexuality it finds a world that is
only male is heat Thunder and
restlessness burdened with the old
prejudice and arrogance with which the
male has always disfigured and burdened
loved because he loves only as a male
and not as a human being there is
something narrow in his sexual feeling
something that seems wild malicious time
bound on eternal which diminishes his
art and makes us it makes it ambiguous
and doubtful we certainly you know if
we're male we can certainly define
ourselves as male but we have to be more
than merely male in relation to the
female and this is something that has
been lost on so many people not just in
our own time but in previous times as
well and it's a danger for the times to
come yoga goes on to suggest this is a
beautiful phrase in letter 5 he says
he's talking about beauty of the girl
motherhood and he says in the man -
there's motherhood it seems to me
physical and mental perhaps the sexes
are more akin than people think and the
great renewal of the world she's
sketching out something utopian here
will consist in one phenomenon so here's
a central
view of real cos about where sexuality
could be going that man and woman freed
from all mistaken aversions and feelings
will seek each other out not as
opposites but as brothers and sisters as
neighbors and will unite as human beings
in order to bear in common simply
earnestly and patiently the heavy sex
that has been laid upon them he's
sketching out here a vision of the
future in which we would approach each
other not simply as man and woman or
whatever other gender relations we may
have where we identify primarily with
that but as human beings without losing
our sexuality but in a way so as to view
the other person as a fellow worker not
as an adversary not as a mark for you
know a pickup artist or the you know
female equivalent of that but as someone
to share not just a life with but labour
with the building of something that
can't be done solely on one's own he
goes on and he talks about new
possibilities for girls and women in
letter seven and he says the girl and
the woman and their new individual
unfolding will be only in passing
imitators of male behavior and
misbehavior and repeaters of male
professions and I think we've seen lots
of that in our own time as you know
waves of feminism have gone through
after the uncertainty of such
transitions it will become obvious that
women were going through the abundance
and variation of those disguises just so
that they could purify their own
essential nature and wash out the
deforming influences of the other sex
he says the humanity of women carried in
her womb through all her suffering and
humiliation will come to light when she
has stripped off the conventions of mere
femaleness femaleness is the opposite of
maleness or that's correlative or
whatever in the transformation of her
outward status and
men who do not feel that approach and
will be astonished by it there will be a
reaction by men to this new possibility
for for living and growing as women and
they can either get with it or they can
go against it but they will eventually
be left behind says this advance at
first very much against the will of the
outdistance men will transform the love
experience and that's another
fundamental key point what sex and love
actually could be and here we get to one
of real cos definitions of what genuine
love ought to be he says the love
experience which is now filled with
error would be changed from the ground
up and reshaped into a relationship that
is meant to be between one human being
and another no longer one that flows
from man to woman so there won't be that
you know unidirectional 'ti anymore and
he says this more human love which will
fulfill itself with infinite
consideration and gentleness and
kindness and clarity and binding and
releasing will resemble what we're now
preparing painfully and with great
struggle the love that consists in this
so here's the characterization of love
that two solitudes protect and border
and greet each other to inés am chiton
solitude is something absolutely central
to the fully developing human being for
real Co that's what's needed for the
younger people to be able to develop the
last thing that I'll point out is that
Rilke says that this transformation is
yet to come but those in the presence
who are solitary who are developing
themselves can prepare the way for this
in the way that they live and that would
extend to their own love and sexual
relations
you